it's called a freak ankle injury that
happened yesterday in practice
and and this this you know
and this is that lightning strike
that that can happen at any time whether
it's practice whether it's game you just
never know and we've been insulated from
that because i think the practices
haven't been as intense as maybe they
would otherwise be in past years in
training camp because they're focused on
getting guys in shape and keeping guys
healthy and keeping guys ready
and we haven't had the cross pollination
with joint practices and preseason games
and now here we are week one of intense
preparations and there's a freak injury
and von miller
by all appearances and based on all
reports done for the year chris huge
blow to a denver defense that was
counting on him to get back to form this
year yeah a huge blow huge ball to all
of us i mean come on this is one of the
the better defensive players in all of
football he's a superstar he's a hall of
famer and as far as the denver broncos
concerned i mean we were excited because
we wanted to see what we thought had a
chance to be one of the best pass rush
duos in football between him and bradley
chubb we were cheated at that last year
because chubb got hurt before that
before last season
so now here we are again with you know
one less person a part of the duo here
and it changes a lot of it changes the
way i think about the denver broncos to
a degree you know they have a young
offense a lot of new young parts a lot
let alone it's a new offensive
coordinator and we know we had the
pandemic and all of that one of the
mainstays of their football team was hey
vic fangio was here this is our second
year in the system von miller you know
the 3-4 defense getting another year
underneath his belt with that and really
you know maybe being able to rely on
that defense if the offense is stubbing
its toe a little bit early in the season
because they're young and a jerry judy
and a drew lock and a noah fan maybe
they're not hitting on all cylinders in
the patch shermer offense so now this
takes away a little bit of that like
insurance factor of their defense and uh
that's where it's a shame because i'm a
big fan of von miller
yeah and you know really raises
questions about his future next year
last year of his contract 17.5 million
this year to not play not that it's his
fault but that's what the broncos are
going to be paying him next year he's
due to make 17.5 million final year of
his contract he'll turn 32 in march so
and there's always been kind of
vague sense that at some point the
broncos are going to decide it's time to
move on from bond miller before he gets
to the end of his contract well there
aren't many more chances for them to
decide it because next year's it they're
going to move him next year or they're
going to keep him or possibly find a way
to extend him but he's going to be 32
yeah and after this injury you're going
to have questions and concerns about
when he's going to be 100 again what's
the dead money mike for next year does
that you got that in front of you right
there as you're looking at it
he is dealing with
not a lot of dead money he's got about
8.45 million in
prior bonus money that he's yet to hit
the cap so it's 4.225 this year 4.225
next year right not nearly the kind of
crippling dead money that you would see
with other guys early in a contract
usually when you get to the back years
of the contract there's nothing left he
did uh a restructuring of some of his
bonus money a couple of years back and
this is still that overflow from that
otherwise you'd have none right now and
there would be no cap consequence of
moving on the question is do you want to
pay him 17.5 million
next year or or do you want to find
someone who would take him do you want
does he want a fresh start is this kind
of a weird way
to you know deal with latter years of
his broncos career and does this make
him want to to begin again with a new
team but but it raises a lot of
questions definitely short term and long
term for the denver broncos and this is
at a time when bradley chubb
is back yeah but is he really back right
he's less than a year removed from a
torn acl and they say it usually takes
at least a full year to even begin to
get back to normal and now he's the guy
and i don't know that he's ready to be
the guy no i i hear you you're right you
know and you know you're right that's
the saying you know with a it's usually
your second season
off of an acl injury where a player
comes back and goes okay i feel a
hundred percent
uh i doubt that bradley chubb feels 100
right now hopefully he can get to that
point you know at some point halfway
through the season wherever that is
uh but yeah i don't think i don't expect
him to be a dominant force as far as off
the edge right away to start the year i
mean that's what was great about the
combo bond miller who i think had a
little bit of a chip on his shoulder
with the way things
kind of unfolded last year it was less
than up to
von miller's standards or his bar there
um so yeah mike and then you look at the
guys that are behind bradley chubb and
von miller it's not necessarily
the greatest group of guys there too
where you're gonna feel comfortable
about like okay they'll be all fine
they'll be fine you know shaquille
barrett's there that's they had him at
one point right before he went to tampa
bay they'll be okay they'll be able to
make it you know there is no guy that
jumps out on their roster like that to
me and uh that's where it's
disheartening mike and and you know as
far as you're talking about this could
be it for von i mean you're right with
denver i never really thought about it
but the severity of this ankle injury i
think will go a long way to see where
where the future lies for this because
if is it achilles tendon
uh that that would scare me that yeah
it's going to be a little while before
he's back to 100 and maybe they do move
on and and find a new home for von
miller
and we've seen it before once you tear
one achilles tendon and i think it's
medically proven you become more likely
to tear the other one whether it's
compensation whether it's just genetics
it's happened to one it's gonna happen
to the other one eventually but you
really have to get to a point where you
ask yourself from the financial
investment that's being made in von
miller uh is it worth it and and that's
something that every team does all the
time with every player on the roster you
tear the name off the back of the jersey
you disregard who it is you make that
cold dispassionate decision because
that's the way nfl football teams and
really every major league sports team
has run they're interchangeable parts
even though kickers and punters are the
most interchangeable they're all
inevitably going to be gone so you
always have a plan for replacing them
either because of injury or they want
out or you want them out or they've
gotten to the point where they're too
old to contribute to at the level their
pay would suggest they're all going to
be gone so you have to have a plan and
john elway the gm of that team and you
know he hey one of his first drafts i
think maybe his very first draft with
the team he got fond miller yeah i think
it was right but but here we are nine
years later how much longer can this
dance last and it could be that
yesterday's injury is the thing that
really pushes it toward miller ending
his career somewhere else and there's
been that consternation in the past
they've been i think at the end of the
2019 season or 2018 there was 25 right
about von miller and the broncos and how
long is this going to last he's been
bracing for it from the moment he signed
that long-term contract he had to fight
for i think that taught him what a
business it really is and he understood
at some point the team's got the power
to say we're just gonna rip up this
contract and see you later and and uh
you know if you brace for that long
enough you eventually just get to the
point where you want it to happen and
get it over with yeah well of course i
mean well yes to a degree but i do think
that denver's a special place for a guy
like von miller you know like you said
they drafted him what the number two
pick in the draft coming out of texas a
m
of course he's had some special seasons
individually
let alone
was a part of a really special season in
that super bowl year where you could
argue he was one of the best defensive
players in football one thing you can
argue is he was the best defensive
player in the playoffs that year whether
it was intercepting tom brady or sacking
him all day in that afc championship
game out there in denver or then you
know
spearheading the charge for a defense
that almost single-handedly won the
super bowl that year i mean it wasn't
the offense that's for sure and he was a
big part of that getting the strip sack
fumbles and and causing all that havoc
back there so this is a hall of fame
type player i don't think you can part
ways with a guy like this easily
and i don't know mike he might have made
enough money and feel comfortable enough
there where
maybe it's something one of those things
where he looks at it after this year it
gives them a home count discount but i
think von miller's that type of guy to
where he might not hold their feet over
the fire and be comfortable just in his
niche in denver and go okay this is
where i was drafted this is where it's
going to end
that's the kind of comment that got you
a side eye yeah
be careful projecting that that attitude
you have for the hometown discount on to
others they may not agree with you and
the bottom line is if
he's healthy he's still one of the best
pass rushers in in football history and
it wasn't that long ago it was before
last season where peter king did the
math about what it would take to catch
bruce smith for the all-time sack record
and von miller was on pace well last
year was disappoint there it is there's
the dag press got side eye the the the
pace has been disrupted dramatically for
von miller between last year which was
very disappointing in vic fangio's first
year as the head coach and now this year
nothing so it's it really raises
questions about his future what he wants
as a football player what the broncos
want and maybe the broncos are just
going to say screw it we're shifting to
offense defense doesn't matter in the
afc west because you ain't stopping the
chiefs anyway let's put our resources in
trying to outscore them and it's going
to be arena football in the afc west if
you want to be successful moving forward
so instead of paying von miller 17.5
million next year they can either spend
that on someone else or bank it on uh
you know guys like drew locke will be
eligible for a new contract after next
year and think of that 17.5 i just it
just flashed in my brain next year
there's a chance the salary cap will
only be 175 million right that's 10 of
the cap going to vaughn miller yeah at a
time when you're not sure whether or not
he's going to be healthy and effective
that they're not going to do it no i
don't know when we talk about it the
more convinced i am going to do no
you're right the more you hear you start
to hear these facts of the matter and
all this i i agree with you now it will
depend on the extent of this injury and
we'll see how severe it is um but i'm
scared when they say a freak injury too
you know yeah the first thing my mind
went to is wait achilles or some sort of
like dislocated ankle where it you know
maybe ripped up a tendon or something
like that uh either way it's not a good
look especially for a guy where his
living is flying around the edge with
300 pound you know people on his back as
he carries them around the edge trying
to sack a quarterback you need your
lower legs and of course need great
strength there
and and this is the reality that we're
now in it was the teddy bridgewater
freak injury during a practice a week or
so before week one of the regular season
in 2016 and this is just part of what we
have to brace for whether it's games
whether it's practices we're back in
that mode now we were lucky and players
were lucky through much of training camp
that it didn't happen maybe because it
wasn't as intense as it could have been
but now the question is are the bodies
ready and are they going to hold up when
the intensity increases and it's going
to get very intense starting tomorrow
night when the texans play the chi
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports